[Música]
drones y misiles por el aire militares
armados por tierra de esta manera Israel
desplegó desde el domingo uno de los más
grandes operativos que ha habido en dos
décadas en yin ubicado en el norte de
las discordania ocupada Allí está un
campamento con 14.000 refugiados
palestinos a los que les quitaron sus
tierras desde 1948 para formar allí el
estado de Israel la avanzada militar
deja por ahora 12 muertos 11 en esa
ciudad y otro más en ramala del otro
lado jamás se atribuyó un ataque que
ocurrió entrelabif donde un hombre lanzó
un carro contra la multitud y luego
comenzó a apuñalar a quienes Estaban
cerca el ataque deja por ahora 8 heridos
y el grupo afirmó que fue en represalia
además el Primer Ministro Israel y
Benjamín explicó que el plan fue para
combatir el terrorismo Y aunque ya
estaba acabando por ahora explicó que no
pararán hasta acabar con los grupos
ilegales
estaban escalado los enfrentamientos y
en esta espiral de violencia que
representan los hechos de llenín hoy en
el debate estábamos en nuestros estudios
con Mauricio Jaramillo jasir analista
internacional y profesor de relaciones
internacionales de la Universidad del
Rosario en Bogotá Colombia y desde otra
ciudad también colombiana Barranquilla
nos acompaña Daniel melamed doctor en
seguridad internacional además en
Jerusalén está nuestro corresponsal para
Israel y los territorios palestinos
Federico Barberena a ellos tres les doy
la bienvenida y a quienes nos sintonizan
y nos escuchan también les abro las
puertas a este debate primero
recomendarles que dejen sus comentarios
y preguntas en las redes sociales con el
hashtag el debate f24 y nos pueden
seguir en Twitter Facebook e Instagram
donde estamos como arroba franz24 raya
al piso es y yo aparezco como arroba
María claguire también saludo muy
especialmente a quienes nos escuchan en
podcast a través de las plataformas de
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
para comenzar este debate e intentar
entender uno de los temas quizás más
complejos que hay en todo el mundo y es
el enfrentamiento histórico entre
israelíes Y palestinos le doy la
bienvenida primero a nuestro
corresponsal Federico para que nos dé un
contexto de lo que ha pasado en los
últimos días bienvenido Federico y
cuéntenos primero en qué consiste
militarmente el operativo en yin Y a qué
se debe este despliegue
Al momento de iniciar la operación que
luego fue bautizada como casa y jardín
un Vocero del ejército la describió como
una redada al nivel de brigada esto
significa involucrar entre mil y dos mil
soldados que han sido apoyados por
tanques sepuldosas y sobre todo ataques
aéreos lanzados desde drones no
tripulados al principio Israel evitó
hablar de operación sino que se refirió
un amplio esfuerzo antiterrorista algo
que pretendía dar a entender una acción
militar no tan prolongada pero al mismo
tiempo está claro que no va a hacer algo
de una sola vez como lo advirtió el
Primer Ministro israelí Benjamín
netañaju por lo que podría haber
ofensivas similares en un corto plazo Lo
cierto es que el mayor despliegue
militar en si Jordania desde la segunda
intifada buscaba en palabras del
portavoz del ejército israelí romper con
una dinámica de milicianos palestinos en
que atacan objetivos israelíes y vuelven
a refugiarse en el campo y fueron dos
episodios los que al parecer aceleraron
a campaña por un lado la detonación de
un artefacto explosivo contra un
blindado israelí hiriendo a siete
soldados durante la redada de hace dos
semanas que causó la muerte de siete
palestinos y un intento fallido de
lanzamiento de cohetes desde jenning
además de los crecientes reclamos de una
operación militar provenientes del ala
más radical del gobierno y del liderazgo
de los colonos Federico pero más allá de
estas ofensivas que usted nos Comenta a
los israelíes han impedido el paso de
ambulancias más de tres mil personas
evacuadas de los campos de refugiados y
hay hospitales que ya no dan abasto
cuéntenos Cuáles son las otras
consecuencias que ha habido Más allá de
los fallecidos
lo que hay es un Halo de destrucción en
todo el campo de refugiados que el
alcalde de llenín comparó con el paso de
un terremoto hay casas y carreteras
destruidas por los bombardeos y el paso
de aplanadoras israelíes que también
ocasionaron cortes de Electricidad y
agua además de faltantes en el
suministro de alimentos hubo colectas de
comida y agua en nablus en el norte de
sijordania ocupada que voluntarios
llevaron a chenín para distribuirlos en
hospitales y centros sociales también
entre 3000 y 4.000 personas se han visto
forzadas a desplazarse para huir de los
combates en el campo de refugiados donde
viven aproximadamente 18.000 personas en
un espacio de medio kilómetro cuadrado
Otro aspecto a tener en cuenta son las
denuncias de bloqueos al ingreso de
socorristas para atender a los heridos
Aunque Israel sostiene que no hay una
orden de evitar que las ambulancias
entren al campo y en materia sanitaria
los hospitales se han visto desbordados
y el lanzamiento de gases lacrimógenos
en los alrededores ha afectado en la
atención de emergencias todo esto no
hace más que la precariedad de una
población que sufre por la deficiencia
de sus infraestructuras y por tener una
de las tasas de desempleo y pobreza más
altas de sijordania y por el otro lado
Israel alega que operan los brazos
armados de jamás la yihadi islámica
Palestina y las brigadas de los mártires
de galaxia Cómo han respondido estos
grupos ante el operativo israelí Además
del ataque que mencionábamos previamente
bien decías María Clara Hay milicianos
de todas las facciones palestinas en
jenning que operan bajo el paraguas de
la llamada brigada de jenning surgida a
la luz de la ausencia de la autoridad
Palestina y de las continuas redadas
israelíeses desde hace un año y medio el
liderazgo de esta brigada es masa de
transversal sus integrantes tienen un
sentido de pertenencia local Más allá de
la organización a la que estén afiliados
y en gran medida son jóvenes que han
nacido durante o después de la conocida
como la batalla de Jenny de 2002 una de
las más sangrientas de la segunda
intifada y que frustrados se vuelcan a
la lucha armada dicho esto dentro del
campo Israel Afirma haber encontrado
poca resistencia en parte porque los
ataques aéreos iniciales Se tomaron
desprevenidos en los milicianos y los
forzaron a retroceder o a huir
Igualmente los llamados jamás la hija de
islámica y los demás grupos son a tomar
represalias aunque no hay indicios
claros de cómo y de momento gaza no se
ha involucrado si bien no se debe
descartar un eventual lanzamiento de si
ha habido un contraataque Si se quiere
individual con el atropellamiento y
acuchillamiento ocurrido hoy ante La Vid
que dejó al menos ocho heridos el
atacante que murió por disparos de
civiles fue identificado como miembro de
jamás que no reivindicó el ataque pero
si lo celebró como una respuesta inicial
por lo que ocurre en sheriny Gracias
Federico por este amplio informe ya con
el contexto que nos da
alquio bienvenida
a Mauricio acompañarnos aquí en nuestros
estudios en Bogotá Mauricio ya nos
contaba nuestro corresponsal que
claramente si bien este ataque comenzó
el domingo no es el primero y
probablemente no el último en qué
contexto se da este ataque en yin y su
dimensión en comparación de otros que
tales Bueno lo primero que hay que
recordar a la gente es que tanto
Jordania como la franja de gases están
ilegalmente ocupadas allí básicamente
opera una suerte de ley Marcial en la
que la fuerza pública israelí fuerza
defensa de israelí o la policía Pues
básicamente actúa en en total impunidad
lo segundo es que Palestina no tiene
ejército entonces obviamente la
correlación de fuerzas es muy grande
tenemos de un lado a un ejército que
tiene bulldozers un ejército que tiene
blindados a un ejército que tiene
Aviación incluso armas nucleares y En
tercer lugar hemos asistido en el último
tiempo una radicalización de la política
israelí
de la coalición de gobierno hoy por
ejemplo hacen partidos abiertamente
homofóbicos como noam o partidos
abiertamente supremacistas como
sionistas religiosos el el ministro de
la seguridad interna y tomar por ejemplo
es una persona que en el pasado ha sido
condenada por apología al odio el el
ministro de finanzas smotrich ha dicho
en repetidas ocasiones Palestina no
existe hay que borrar a los palestinos
del mapa Entonces en este contexto
asistimos a una radicalización de la
violencia que se parece hasta cierto
punto a la última enfada porque lo que
habíamos visto en los últimos años Era
sobre todo radicalización de la
violencia en el territorio de gaza Sí
donde tiene su centro de operaciones Si
se quiere jamás pero desde 2019-2020 a
raíz de una serie de expulsiones y a
raíz de que el proceso de colonización
ha venido aumentando esa violencia que
antes era casi que exclusiva de gasas en
el último tiempo se ha venido
trasladando a zonas que antes no no eran
tan violentas como en el caso de de
Jerusalén también expulsiones
recientemente y ahora lo vemos en el
norte de cisjordania en en yin y no se
nos olvide que hace poco más de un año
fue asesinada en circunstancias
similares
una periodista de la cadena al jazzira
por parte del ejército de israelí de un
tiro en la cabeza a pesar de que estaba
debidamente identificada y hasta la
fecha no tenemos una sola persona
responsable que esté compareciendo ante
la justicia básicamente Este es el
contexto en el que hay una desproporción
enorme en el correlato de fuerzas
24 un placer conectar con usted aquí en
el debate Le quiero preguntar si usted
está de acuerdo con este punto de
Mauricio en que no hay una correlación
de fuerzas equilibrada y que hemos visto
una radicalización de la violencia en
lugares ya no solo en casa sino también
en cisjordania actualmente
Muchas gracias por la invitación un
saludo por supuesto para ti María Clara
para corresponsal y para Mauricio Bueno
lo primero que me gustaría puntualizar
frente a los comentarios del profesor
Mauricio es que a partir de el año 2022
alrededor de 19 hechos de violencia que
fueron perpetrados contra civiles
israelís superpetradores
Buscar un refugio en Jenny o en las
áreas circundantes
en el 2023 van alrededor de 50 ataques
hasta la fecha cobrando la vida de
nuevamente ciudadanos israelíes y cuyo
perpetradores se ubican sobre el área
Que aquí hay que hacer una distinción
muy importante una cosa es el campo de
refugiados original creaba a principios
de la década y otra es la cantidad de
crecimiento desbordado alrededor del que
casi convierte allí en una ciudad de
alrededor de cuarenta mil entre cuarenta
mil y cuarenta y cinco mil personas de
esas 45.000 personas más o menos
trabajan en Israel por lo tanto yo
puntualizaría que no es una operación
contra la población Palestina no es una
operación contra el campo de refugiados
el establecimiento político y militar de
Israel ha establecido de manera muy
clara que es una operación con unos
objetivos puntuales esos objetivos
buscan degradar las capacidades
operativas de las milicias palestinas
que operan en que ustedes muy bien lo
han planteado cobijan a todo un
escenario bastante amplio de
organización me gustaría puntualizar
esto además la Corte Suprema de Israel
en una sentencia siete seis nueve del
dos
estableció de manera muy puntual entre
el estado de Israel y las milicias
palestinas existe un estado de conflicto
armado internacional y con lo cual
rompía las paradigmas que hasta aquel
momento esperaban donde fundamentalmente
se hablaba de que los conflictos armados
internacionales solamente podían existir
fuera únicamente concebibles entre un
estado y otro estado y la Corte Suprema
de Israel estableció que efectivamente
de un estado y organizaciones armadas no
estatales podía existir este tipo de
enfrentamientos y esto es importante
establecerlo porque Mauricio Establece
que pues Palestina no tiene ejército
quizás no tiene un ejército unificado
bajo un control jerárquico digamos
vertical Pero sí tiene múltiples
milicias alrededor del territorio y
milicias que tienen capacidad de llevar
a cabo muchos actos de violencia como lo
hemos establecido a lo largo de digamos
ustedes mismos en el programa Y a partir
de mi análisis Entonces es importante
que esto se tenga en cuenta para
contextualizar también un poco creo que
hay información que se puede adicionar
para hacer del del análisis y de la
discusión mucho más amplia mucho más
completa y a mí me gustaría puntualizar
con esto y con esta parte termino
mi primera intervención Jeremy bahuen
corresponsal de un medio de comunicación
prestigioso tan precioso como ustedes en
frases veinticuatro la bbc ha señalado
queenín el campo de Jenny está
completamente bajo el control de
milicias palestinas como jamás y la
yihad islámica por lo tanto el
establecimiento militar a israelí Busca
editar que en cisjordania se degrade la
situación de seguridad
tal como en alguna oportunidad ocurrió
desde desde casa y precisamente para
enfatizar con usted Daniel en un punto
que hablaba Mauricio y es la correlación
de fuerzas Le quiero preguntar en el
marco de lo que ha ocurrido
una cifra y es usted dice que si bien
los palestinos no tienen un ejército si
hay múltiples milicias con una capacidad
de ejercer violencia que también se ha
visto en los últimos meses y en los
últimos años pero cómo comparar esta
fuerza
relativamente o respecto al ejército
israelí que como bien lo decía Mauricio
tiene una capacidad nuclear y además es
uno de los más avanzados
tecnológicamente en el mundo y otro dato
y es 8 dice que en los seis primeros
meses de 2023 han muerto 147 palestinos
Jordania y Jerusalén del este en
comparación de 23 israelíes
mire aquí me parece importante mantener
un área de foco que
a mi juicio ilustra bastante bien La
complejidad del asunto No yo no quiero
enviar mensajes de que la situación aquí
digamos es sencilla es muy compleja el
escalamiento creo que fundamentalmente
no beneficia a ninguna parte en el
puerto mediano plazo
pero aquí hay que también es claro
digamos encuadrarlo que ocurre en el
marco teórico de lo que es una guerra
híbrida y la guerra híbrida esa
correlación de fuerza no resta el nivel
de amenaza que puede tener en este caso
el estado que tiene mayor o goza de
mayores capacidades militares tal como
lo han planteado la guerra híbrida y si
usted me permite la la explicación el
término híbrido usualmente es concebido
para hablar de la mezcla de dos cepas o
de dos elementos en este caso una guerra
híbrida es la mezcla de guerra
convencional es decir capacidades aéreas
navales o terrestres y también
instrumentos no o propios de la guerra
simétrica como guerra de guerrillas
operación de actores armados no
estatales en medio de entornos urbanos
ciberataques
utilización de
armamento digamos prohibidos por los
instrumentos normativos del derecho
internacional
llámese Minas antipersonas utilización
de elementos de guerra cibernética y
todas estas circunstancias Si usted me
lo permite también vale la pena también
destacar han venido implementándose en
el teatro de operaciones de este ciclo
trágico de acción reacción entre las
fuerzas de defensa de Israel y milicias
palestinas y el punto emblemático donde
esta guerra híbrida digamos se inauguró
en el en medio de los enfrentamientos
entre las partes fue la guerra del lío
del 2006 donde otro actor armado Estatal
tenía capacidades inclusive de impactar
una corbeta la corbeta hanite a partir
obviamente del fortalecimiento de sus
capacidades militares Entonces el hecho
de que no sean un ejército puntual el
hecho de que no tenga una estructura
jerárquica y cohesionada alrededor de
todos los territorios palestinos no
degrada el nivel de amenaza que la
ciudadanía enfrenta Y por supuesto las
propias fuerzas de seguridad y muy
brevemente que respondería frente al
balance o la comparación de los muertos
bueno Yo lamento la la pérdida de
cualquier vida no no es un elemento que
me genere por supuesto satisfacción creo
que es una circunstancia muy dolorosa
aspiro y espero que la situación logre
mitigarse en las próximas horas es un
elemento que hay que seguir por supuesto
pero hace parte también de una compleja
realidad y es el atrincheramiento que
muchas de estas organizaciones armadas
estas milicias palestinas desarrollan
sus actividades su capacidad es
operativas su estructura organizacional
en medio de entornos urbanos
precisamente poblados como ustedes nos
han planteado anteriormente es muy
difícil plantear que una operación
militar salga 100% bien y que no se
cometan errores eso eso solo pasará en
las películas en la vida real está lleno
de un escenario cambiante con
circunstancias que desafían las mejores
planificaciones en términos de
estrategia militar por supuesto estas
circunstancias son absolutamente
dolorosas Mauricio ahora le quiero
contar preguntar un punto que nos
señalaba janiel anteriormente Y que es
el mismo que ha defendido el gobierno de
Israel y es que estos operativos en yin
no son contra la población civil sino
contra las milicias y se han referido a
jenning como el centro de operaciones de
diferentes grupos armados y recordemos
usted nos hablaba de un aumento de la
violencia y lo hemos visto también por
ejemplo con la creación de nuevos grupos
como La Guarida del león en la plusa o
la llamada brigada de jenning que fue
fundada por un miembro de la yihad
islámica Palestina A qué se debe este
repunte y si esto en cierta medida
justifica o no estos operativos
israelíes Bueno lo primero el repunte
tiene que ver con la llegada de una
trompa a Estados Unidos y la legitimidad
internacional del proceso de
colonización que en términos generales
los gobiernos de Estados Unidos habían
Si se quiere de alguna manera condenado
por lo menos indirectamente o habían
puesto como una condición necesaria para
que hubiera Paz entre realidades y
palestinos lo que ocurre con Donald
Trump básicamente con este famoso plan
de paz Es que le va a decir al gobierno
de Benjamín tanyahu nosotros estamos
dispuestos a apoyar la colonización de
Six Jordania qué va a pasar en la
práctica obviamente los palestinos van a
empezar a defenderse por ejemplo hablaba
de a lo que es usual en en La retórica
del gobierno de israelí a esto es una
democracia a Independencia está la Corte
Suprema sí es independiente pero la
Corte Suprema también participa de la
expulsión de palestinos como pasó en por
ejemplo en en Jerusalén donde la Corte
Suprema lo que hace es utilizar el
derecho para legitimar la ocupación
utilizar el derecho para legalizar las
expulsiones que son según no según
Palestina según organizaciones no
gubernamentales y Naciones Unidas a
todas luces ilegales Claro entiendo lo
que dice Daniel es que los palestinos
tienen de todas maneras una milicias no
solamente no hay te mando en esas
milicias sino que esas milicias no
pueden controlar las fronteras es decir
No hay ninguna posibilidad de que uno
equipare el control por ejemplo que
tiene sobre las fronteras los palestinos
están encerrados por parte del ejército
israelí entonces decir por ejemplo que
las milicias palestinas ejercen de
alguna manera una labor equiparable a
los ejércitos pues no no tiene nada que
ver con la práctica lo que hacen
administraciones es defender los
palestinos obviamente de ninguna manera
uno puede estar de acuerdo con algunos
de los ataques que lanzan contra la
población israelí no hay en ese sentido
no hay en ese sentido una guerra porque
no hay dos bandos lo que hay es un bando
Insisto que tiene un ejército regular
reconocido internacionalmente que recibe
además armas que tiene una industria
militar contra una población que no
tiene que explicar la gente los
palestinos por ejemplo no tienen
blindados no tienen tanques no reciben
fusiles de asalto no tienen batería
antiaérea entonces cada vez que Israel
dice es imposible porque es una zona
donde hay mucha densidad lo decía
Federico
18.000 personas en en en en en en medio
en medio kilómetro pero los palestinos
están digamos que
hacinados en buena medida por la
ocupación es decir el grado de
hacinamiento el grado de densidad que
encontramos en en
gaza tiene que ver con la misma
ocupación entonces básicamente el cuadro
que uno puede ver es que lo que antes
era o supuestamente era es por algo es
decir eran ataques en los que Israel
decía nos estamos defendiendo se han
convertido en ataques que hoy Son
sistemáticos por eso hoy hoy mismo
amnistía internacional está diciendo
detengamos en la parte porque
básicamente tres prácticas que hemos
visto en jenning una limpieza étnica es
decir la desaparición constante de
aldeas palestinas insisto el ministro de
finanzas israelí es un tipo que dice a
los cuatro vientos que hay que arrasar a
los palestinos y que hacerlos
desaparecer dos el
que es básicamente la población árabe
excluida en doble medida los árabes que
tienen ciudadanía israelí que están muy
por debajo del nivel de vida de los
israelíes y obviamente los palestinos
que sufren los dejamenes de la ocupación
y En tercer lugar el genocidio sí a los
palestinos los están acabando de manera
sistemática no hay ningún estado en la
Esfera occidental que practique de
manera tan regular la pena de muerte de
facto contra los menores incluso menores
de edad que no saben ni siquiera porque
están ahí y todo en la misma retórica de
que es una amenaza híbrida es que se
meten con la población si eso es así
entonces que le den a los palestinos la
oportunidad de tener un ejército y que
ese ejército se encargue de controlar
los grupos terroristas pero si parecía
no tiene de ninguna manera de defenderse
Tiene que recurrir desafortunadamente
estas milicias Y qué Cómo se puede
comparar la segunda intifada de 2002 con
Edge estos hechos de llenín o son
incomparables
a comienzos de los 2000 había un Si se
quiere
ambiente internacional veníamos de los
acuerdos de oslo para Estados Unidos era
importante la paz en Oriente medio en
este momento Si no estoy mal estaba
George Bush que trató de lanzar un
proceso de paz Rescatando lo que había
quedado de oslo con Los acuerdos de
Anápolis a Europa le interesaba lo que
pasa en medio oriente hoy para mí la
estación es más crítica porque uno a
Estados Unidos no le interesa la paz del
medio oriente dos Europa está centrada
en la guerra en Ucrania y tres tenemos
una radicalización del gobierno de
israelí que no teníamos creo que insisto
Este es el gobierno más supremacista en
la historia de Israel desde 1947 hasta
nuestros días No habíamos tenido un
estado tan alejado de lo que quiso
bengurión No hemos tenido un estado tan
alejado de la laicidad No hemos tenido
por ejemplo la declaración de Israel
como estado judío no habíamos tenido la
aplicación sistemática de pena de muerte
contra menores y menos aún creo que los
que fundaron el estado de Israel estaban
muy lejos de imaginarse el discurso que
hoy tienen personas como el ministro de
seguridad interna o el ministro de
finanzas
y precisamente en lo que usted llama la
radicalización cuando el gobierno del
sexto gobierno de Benjamín natanyahu
asumió el poder este año y formó la
coalición dentro de su plan de gobierno
avalaron expandir la ocupación a los
territorios palestinos y apuntar hacia
eso janiel le quiero preguntar usted
está de acuerdo en que ha habido una
radicalización y en que esto ha afectado
la espiral de violencia que hemos visto
Hola
mire yo puedo coincidir con con Mauricio
en que desde ambos sectores
existen fuerzas muy extremistas que de
alguna manera
tratan de imponer su agenda
para la consecución de sus propios
objetivos No necesariamente la
consecución la consecución de los
objetivos que beneficien a sus
respectivos pueblos hay un elemento que
a mí me llama poderosamente la atención
y creo que es importante insertar en la
discusión
y cómo ha sido y tiene que ver o gira
alrededor de cómo ha sido el proceso de
fortalecimiento de estas milicias
Dónde está la autoridad nacional
Palestina pues literalmente
la autoridad nacional Palestina puede
que exista y ejerza una digamos
representatividad política pero en el
terreno
no es la autoridad
económica no es la autoridad política y
mucho menos estar muchísimo más lejos de
ser la autoridad militar
del sitio Entonces cómo es que se
convierte en este punto de grandes
concentraciones de capacidades militares
de milicias Creo que vale la pena
ahondar sobre esto coincido con algo que
dijo Mauricio es importante establecerlo
hay unas digamos una tasa de desempleo
muy alta en alrededor de 35% no es la
más alta alrededor de los territorios
palestinos pero es considerablemente
alta creo que esto es importante
resaltarlo porque habla también de la
del fracaso de la autoridad nacional
Palestina para poder suplir las
necesidades que requiere la propia
población Palestina es una autoridad
nacional Palestina que tiene alrededor
del 80% desde desaprobación no según mis
datos no según mi opinión
opinión de Jalil shikaki un académico
palestino de muy gran renombre director
del centro de cuentas palestinas en su
última entrega su último estudio habla
de alrededor del 80% de desaprobación
del presidente de la autoridad nacional
Palestina más muda paz 80% de partidos
que piden su renuncia y que de alguna
manera ha llevado a que estas
organizaciones estas milicias lleguen y
tengan la capacidad de inyectar recursos
económicos muy importantes en aras de
ampliar y multiplicar su capacidad
operativa en la zona Y ser receptor de
muchos jóvenes que buscan de alguna u
otra manera mejorar sus condiciones
ahora bien teniendo eso Claro pues no
podemos tampoco olvidar que este
contexto está netamente ligado con un
tema sobre el cual muy poco se habla
quisiera plantearlo como el tema de
discusión es el vínculo de muchas de
estas milicias palestinas con
organizaciones
vinculadas con el narcotráfico narco
estados una problemática que nosotros
conocemos muy bien en Colombia y que
sabemos cómo eh suple Como permite
proporcionar la gasolina necesaria para
mantener las capacidades operativas y
militares en estas milicias y esos
narcos costados estas narco
organizaciones precisamente vienen del
Líbano con presencia de escolar o del
propio gobierno sirio eh devallar una
una reciente investigación importante
periodística de Emir nader otro
corresponsal de bbc árabe habla
recientemente la pueden buscar en
internet habla del vínculo de actores de
muy alto nivel dentro del gobierno sirio
me estoy refiriendo por ejemplo en
general de asantilar y la propia gesto
escolar dentro de estas economías
ilegales En clave del narcotráfico que
buscan inyectar recursos a estas
milicias palestinas para convertirse en
los grandes financiadores de estas
capacidades militares esto no que sea
pues secreto y que está en clave
nuevamente lo reitero con las
características que tiene este escenario
de guerra híbrida que es mucho más
complejo porque una simple narrativa que
hablan de una un trasfondo geopolítico
bastante complejo y la suma de varias
fuerzas alrededor de Israel en gaza en
Jordania en el sur del Líbano y más allá
usted habla entonces de tres causas
principales por las que aumentan las
milicias en yin uno es la alta tasa de
desempleo 2 la falta de una autoridad
Palestina que ejerza un control efectivo
y tres la combinación de estas milicias
con grupos internacionales ligados al
narcotráfico Mauricio usted está de
acuerdo Cuáles son las causas que usted
da para el incremento de las milicias en
yin y sobre todo Qué hacer ante este
aumento Bueno lo que con lo que sí
coincido es que básicamente ha habido
una desinstitucionalización de la
autoridad nacional Palestina que no es
solamente individuable los palestinos
tampoco se trata
de sacarle responsabilidad a magmutabas
que tiene muchísimo que ver la la manera
en que ha malgastado por ejemplo
recursos que han llegado por la vida de
la cooperación internacional pero no
podemos desconocer que por ejemplo la
autoridad nacional Palestina se crea en
los 90 con Los acuerdos de oslo con una
serie de promesas que Israel ha venido
incumpliendo de manera reiterativa entre
ellas por ejemplo la propia ocupación
en la misma época de Donald Trump por
ejemplo le fueron congelados ingentes
recursos con el chantaje este de que los
palestinos tienen que aceptar un plan de
paz que no era un plan de paz obviamente
era un plan para legalizar legitimar
obviamente la ocupación entonces
evidentemente acá se mezclan dos cosas
de un lado la inefectividad de la
dirigencia Palestina es cierto no ha
habido un relevo hay un espacio pequeño
para términos generales es quien ha
controlado El Poder y en esa crisis de
gobernabilidad hemos visto es que
pequeños grupos han venido ganando
espacios lo que pasó por ejemplo con el
entre golpe de estado que da jamás en la
franja de gaza es es muestra de ello el
hecho de que por ejemplo hoy jamás este
reivindicando ciertos objetivos en sí
Jordán y que es algo relativamente raro
pero eso pasó Ya lo hemos visto en en
Jerusalén
entonces lo que vemos concretamente es
una multiplicación efectivamente del
poder en la medida en que se erosiona el
poder de la autoridad nacional Palestina
pero ese poder también se relaciona
porque la comunidad internacional le ha
venido soltando la mano a los palestinos
pongo el ejemplo de las últimas grandes
selecciones legislativas en Palestina se
le dijo a la gente
crean en la democracia voten porque
ustedes quieran y la gente en masa
terminó votando por jamás Entonces qué
hizo Estados Unidos que hizo la
comunidad internacional aplicar un
castigo colectivo entonces lo que decía
Daniel esta operación no es contra la
población de yenín eso es lo que dicen
las autoridades israelíes pero en
términos generales en términos generales
los bloqueos el encierro estas
operaciones militares así no quieran
Llamar de esa manera a quien castiga esa
palestino promedio es cuando uno ve por
ejemplo que los palestinos no tienen
derecho a la vida no tienen derecho a
dar locomoción no tienen derecho a la
salud son humillados públicamente se les
dieran obviamente los derechos
procesales por eso hablaba de niños
cientos de niños que están en cárceles
sin saber ni siquieramente porque están
pues lo que uno ve ahí Es que hay una
autoridad Palestina pues evidentemente
está corta y Cerro diciendo lo siguiente
los narcotráfico es cierto pero también
pasan Israel hoy tenemos una
conflictividad enorme entre esa
población de esos dos millones de árabes
ciudadanos israelíes por culpa del
narcotráfico y ha hecho el estado de
israelí es dejar que se maten es dejar
que se maten en Vendetta es decir mirar
por otro lado Entonces lo narcotráfico
no es algo exclusivamente delgable a
Siria al Líbano a los palestinos porque
la misma Israel ha sido condescendiente
para precisamente continuar con este
régimen de aparte y ya para ir cerrando
nuestro debate Mauricio quiero comenzar
con usted para las conclusiones y es que
se puede esperar porque de un lado
escuchamos
diciendo que habrá más operaciones así
hasta acabar con el terrorismo y del
otro lado se están multiplicando los
múltiples poderes precisamente por lo
que usted llama la erosión de la
autoridad nacional Palestina qué esperar
entonces bueno yo creo que
desafortunadamente va a haber un
recrudecimiento de la violencia como lo
hemos visto en los últimos dos años
el gran reto para la comunidad
internacional es así como han
reaccionado frente a la invasión de
Rusia a Ucrania así como han acusado a
Putin y han hecho presión sobre él es
importante que es una limpieza hacer
presión sobre el gobierno de israelí
quien es además quien tiene el control
de la situación en segundo lugar se
tiene que reactivar la financiación de
la autoridad nacional Palestina para que
haya una presión y efectivamente haya un
relevo generacional en esa autoridad y
En tercer lugar tiene que Cesar la
ocupación tiene que Cesar el apartheid y
tiene que estar el genocidio Si eso no
cesa desafortunadamente vamos a seguir
con violencia en toda la región de
oriente medio y su conclusión que se
puede esperar y Cuáles serían las
posibles soluciones
Mire yo difiero discrepo de de algo en
los cuales no es la primera vez que
digamos he tenido la oportunidad de
conversar con Mauricio sobre sobre el
tema hay una digamos escuela de
pensamiento alrededor de el análisis del
conflicto para el chino israelí que
atribuye el deterioro de los indicadores
y de seguridad y de la violencia a la
ocupación como tal
yo discrepo de esa digamos premisa
máxima no la ocupación de las Naciones
Unidas habla de ocupación a partir del
67 Cuando llegamos al año 67 la guerra
de los seis días por lo menos mal
contado llevamos 50 años de conflicto
dependiendo de qué momento empiece usted
a tomar como referente inicio del mismo
decir 50 años antes de la ocupación ya
había episodios de violencia sistemática
y generalizada entre las partes Así que
yo creo que la ocupación es un problema
Por supuesto que no no pretendo
disminuir digamos su complejidad pero no
creo que sea el problema
país causal de este elemento y quiero
terminar mi intervención con una
reflexión muy importante mira en
términos geopolíticos que Mauricio
conoce bastante bien hay por lo menos
tres elementos que terminan
condicionando los conflictos
territoriales primero la existencia de
enormes recursos naturales por ejemplo
petróleo diamante lo que sea y dos
grupos que intentan controlar el segundo
la en los fines estratégicos que el
control de cierto territorio permite a
uno de los grupos y por lo tanto no está
dispuesto a cederlos frente al otro en
ese una montaña el control de un río
algo estratégico que le brinda una
ventaja militar y el tercer elemento
habla de connotaciones religiosas los
tres elementos en mayor o menor medida
los tres elementos están en medio del
conflicto armado y eso no se va a
terminar con el tema de la ocupación la
ocupación es uno de los elementos que
condiciona este conflicto ya miraremos
entonces que sigue ocurriendo en yin y
en los territorios palestinos y también
en Israel a Mauricio Jaramillo jasir y
janiel Valadez Bisbal Gracias por
acompañarnos y también a nuestro
corresponsal Federico Barberena la
producción de este debate estuvo a cargo
de Andrés y la de los invitados con
Tania Herrera sigan conectados con Franz
[Música]